it's an embarrassing confession but for
a certain group among us it's fair to
say that a great deal of our lives is
spent asking essentially the same
question week after week always with the
same blend of frustration despair and
puzzlement
why am i so lonely
why in other words do i so often find
myself at odds in social groups
why can't i more easily connect with
people why do i not have more friends
worthy of the name
it's tempting to jump to the darkest
conclusion because i am awful because
there is something wrong with me because
i deserve to be hated
but the real answer is likely to be far
less punitive and in its way far more
logical
we the isolated members of the tribe are
lonely for a very firm and forgivable
reason because we are interested in
introspection and they the others for
all their intelligence and wit and
strength of mind are not
they may have many hobbies and passions
and lots to say about a host of things
but they are simply not interested in
looking deeply inside themselves
it is not their idea of fun to go into
their childhoods to trace the links
between their emotions and their actions
or to lie for a long time in a bath or a
bed processing events in their interior
lives
introspection is not their thing they
haven't told us this in so many words
and they never will
they don't even realize it perhaps
we simply have to surmise that this is
the case on the basis of external
evidence that we never feel we have much
to say to them even though objectively
there might be so much to share
it's the lack of introspection that
explains why conversation with them so
often gets stuck in odd places
discussing the price of train tickets or
the best way to prepare muffins or what
so and so from university whom we never
really knew or liked is now doing
it explains why when we try to nudge the
conversation onto something more
intimate and vulnerable we seem somehow
never to manage and end up in yet more
rounds of discussion about the sports
results or the new political scandal
they aren't necessarily cold but it can
certainly seem that way because they
aren't interested in communicating what
is really going on in their hearts
sometimes we can be surprised when out
of the blue they tell us that they
consider us to be a close friend
we should accept that most of our
acquaintances however much they might in
theory want to be friendly do not want
to do so at the cost of looking inside
their own minds
and we for our part are lonely because
we are operating with a notion of
intimacy that is far less common than we
torture ourselves by imagining
we will be blessed if we meet just one
or two people in a lifetime who want to
play as we do
the rest of the time we shouldn't
compound our problems by feeling lonely
that we're lonely
it's painful but utterly understandable
our favorite pastime however noble it
might be is a very unusual one indeed
how to survive the modern world is a
guide to coping with the present it
explores why some key features of modern
life including capitalism advertising
mass media and the rise of individualism
can have harmful effects on our
psychological health